欢迎收看最佛心幽默的财经节目
理财达人秀
我是李兆华
好 今天台股有点沙尾盘
跌了400多点
重点在今天的量
上市量只有6000多亿
创下了今年应该是第二低量
当然因为今天南部有放所谓的下雨假
希望南部的朋友能够平安
那台北呢
也有可能这个礼拜迎来所谓的台风价
所以交投是比较清淡的
但这礼拜是有大事情的哦
回答要公布财报了
全球的央行年会
也要决策美国的利率走向
因为现在美国所谓的长债
公债的殖利率往上标
对于他们的科技股相对不利哦
台股也呈现比较闷哦
属于中高位阶的横盘整理
但是我们说量低
然后横盘整理就是等表态啊
那现在到底该做哪一些的观察
酝酿着下一波的多头再攻呢
来欢迎今天的三位来宾
第一位是股市时工永年老师
好 言人老师说量缩当然要留意
今天有诸多的因素加在一起
但是因为这礼拜的两件大师刚刚讲的
会大财报还有全球的央行年会
将会决定一个方向出来
现在看起来利多的因子是比较多的
但无论如何我们找真的委屈
真的好股票
例如台积电的设备供应链
有人还在年线附近
等一下帮您摔出来
还有电力概念股
虽然光宝科超级厉害
那其他人跟不跟呢
有人老说快要跟上去咯
好第二位是我们的题材猎人汉伟哥
好汉伟哥也说
在这个美债值利率往上跑的情况下
所谓高本一比高本梦比的科技股
会比较压抑哦
今天也很明显资金跑到哪里去
高息的价值
科技也好
传产也好
例如航海王
例如说记忆体模组
这两个族群怎么看呢
航海王涨一段了
今天出现黑K了
是给我们上传的机会吗
好第三位呢
是我们的冠军操盘手云翔哥
好云翔哥说
不要忘记一件事
台股前一阵子涨的都是涨价题材
但最近涨价题材哦
参差不齐
忽涨忽叠
他锁定了一个叫细晶圆
因为呢细晶圆已经出来讲话了
真的是确定涨价功率元件
也說10月要再漲一波細節源到功率元件等一下幫您挑另外每一股我們看到SuperSS的股价是真的往上走但我们的低轨位新概念股位积都很低
今天有独家的隐藏版
告诉你
有人的本益比区间
真的已经很便宜了
帮您挑出来
好 首先有请悠年老师
好 这个今天6000多亿的量
一开盘看到APP是5000亿左右
想怎么了
南部在放假
没错
美股也是一个比较压抑的状态
这礼拜有回答财报
华许也要讲话
那台积电的设备
你有找到很便宜的标的
还有电力股
OK 好
这个一定要跟大家讲一下
成交量的问题
因为成交量今天减少
当然两个原因
第一个就是
因为这礼拜的消息面
特别的重要
所以大家都来盘整
就要秉析以待
另外一个当然就是因为
下雨假的关系
我们先看
这个礼拜最重要的
就是两件事情
一個是輝達財報
一個是這個Jackson Hall
就是全球央行的會議
那麼這個是市場的看法
就是本季它營收大概是920.6億美元
年增97%
那調整後的EPS
預估2.09美元
年增99%
其實表現都很好
大家預估它的表現都很好
那當然如果它能夠
兩個都能夠超過100%的話
那就應該是優於市場預期了
不過呢更重要的是
大家現在都是看下一季
如果他下一季的财测
能够突破1030亿的话
那就是真正的优于市场预期了
那他就有机会涨了
那如果呢
因为呢
挥达他公布出来之后
因为他是压轴的
其他的这个AI概念股
都已经公布财报了
他是压轴的
而且他也是最重要的
所以呢
他如果一公布出来
那优于市场预期的话
那股价就会涨了
他的挥达股价涨
那我们台湾的电子股
几乎都要跟着涨了
那另外呢
就是這個全球央行會議
其實現在全球央行會議
我覺得它的重要性
不及輝達的財報
是
因為華絮已經講了
以後我不會預測
不會告訴大家以後
我準備要做什麼
不做什麼事情
所以它應該不會有
太明確的說法
那麼至於說這樣子的話
那我們就看一下
這個美國的股市
現在大家看一下
它好像要做一個圓弧頭了
按照波浪理論上來講
還會有一波的跌勢
应该还会有一波跌线
不就我们会不会拖下去吗
那是哪个也
如果说用技术面纯粹就技术面来看的话确实是很擔心確實很擔心可是在過去的這個三四年裡面應該從2022年年底一直到現在
那個美國股市它經常會怎麼樣
做了一個投出來
然後直接V型反轉
對 它這一波也有這個味道
其實很長
對 它也有這個味道
所以我是覺得說
目前還不是很確定
那我們還是等到
這個輝達公布財報之後
那個時候走勢明確了
我們再來用力一點
好 虎視的慣性在最近
可能因為AI的興起
資金的熱潮
有一點改變
沒錯
但我們台股的形態
看起來比納斯達克強蠻多
對 因為他做了一個頭部
我們還沒有
我們並沒有
我們一直橫盤整理
OK 橫盤整理
那到了今天是
這個橫向盤整的第四天
那陳教練一直說想
其實這是好事不是壞事
因為橫向盤整的話
量一直縮小就表示
大家都不敢動了
你不敢動的話
籌碼反而會變得比較乾淨
好 那我們之前有講過
上禮拜有講過
我不認為它會拉回來打第二隻腳
可是萬一它拉回來的話
就碰到4萬點的話
那一定破
一定破
就變成A B C波的下跌了
可是我們往好處想的話
在這邊盤一盤
這個禮拜說不定就可以上去了
這邊就變成A波 B波 C波的一個反彈
這個C波可以到哪裡
應該可以突破18218了
好 那看多的理由就是
第一個這個主技術預估
今年的GDP年增率11.05%
39年的新高
整體市場上市上櫃公司
7月份營收5.79兆
年增率47.5%
我覺得這兩個數字都很可怕
你知道嗎
這好成這個樣子
你說它要跌破4萬點
然後再向下這個測試
實在不可思議
除非就是好幾隻黑天鵝一起飛起來
可是也有不利的多頭的地方
量能不足
大概平均要1.2兆左右
它才有機會突破這18218
這個大家可能要做個參考
好 然後我們就看台積電
也是在等待
對
是在等回答嗎
我覺得有可能
因為它等得更久了
你看他等了多久
他見到高點以後
到這個禮拜第十週了就是週K十週的橫盤十周 越盘越小 有没有越盘越小 区间越小到最后他就必须要决定
他到底要喷出还是要跳水
到最后K棒都比线还要小了
对 没错
可是他现在就是要决定
以后要是喷出
还是到底要跳水
可是我觉得他喷出的机会会比较大
想不出跳水的理由
如果他的获利一直成长的话
没有错
因為你看一下
它外資預估2027年EPS 143
所以預估
我們現在用今天的收盤價來算
它預估這個本益比才16.7倍
對台積電來講16.7倍
實在是太委屈了對不對
所以我們看一下
如果用143塊
乘以它20倍的本益比的話
2860塊
所以剛才我們也講了
盤整已經到尖端了
馬上就要決定未來趨勢方向
我會比較建議
如果你真的不知道
买什么股票的话
分批成接
定时定额分批成接
台积电就是万一它是跳水的话
或者跌下来的话
你就按这个定时定额分批成接就好了
不吃亏的
因为这个明年的EPS
公司自己透明的说法
都说到已经
不知道要怎么说了
对不对
OK 好
那么至于说台积电走得不错
我们就看一下台积电概念股
其實有一些社會反彈也滿兇的
所以剛剛很好奇說
有誰你覺得很委屈呢
OK 好
那麼我覺得是這個陽機工程
是比較委屈一點
因為你看一下
這一波從低點反彈
你看 怎麼突然有一個1.5
沒有彈的
因為我剛才看萬潤也彈了45%
其實他們現在都已經有點拉回了
如果是碰到最高點的話
其實都不止這樣子
這些彈不多
對 其實陽機工程
我們這樣子給大家看一下
陽金工程它其實當初
有反彈到還滿高的位置
到了750幾塊
像是760塊這個附近
它是從602塊彈起來的
所以其實彈得滿高的
它之所以它今天會變成611塊
其實最主要原因是因為它除全息了
在8月20號它已經除全息了
所以它直接那個跳空下來
那我是沒有把它還原全息值
那為什麼不還原呢
因為你看一看
它跌到年限
它跌到年限在這邊守了兩天
那年限為什麼跌到年限
我會注意呢
因為它在去年的
大概差不多10月以後
10月以後
就再也沒有碰過年限了
所以在將近一年的期間裡面
第一次碰年限
應該都會有相當強力的支撐
而且以它現在的這個
股價來講的話
它預估它的本益比才19倍
也算是還滿低的
尤其是因為它的在手訂單
早就超過500億了
能見度已經到2027年年底了
所以這檔股票我是覺得說
它的股價以目前來看
是应该已经碰到长期的支撑了
应该可以值得注意一下
好 所以到年限
当然还原的话是没有
但是难得看到它这么便宜
是 对
一看六百多块
真的口水都流下来了
是
好 来 然后我们看一下
就是老AI的这个概念股
有围绕在回答的Var Rubin
第三季末要出货了
对 因为第三季末要开始大量出货
Rubin這個系列了
所以我是覺得說
已經沉浮了很久的
這個老AI伺服器
還有散熱還有電力
都應該是我們接下來要觀察的重點
當然因為散熱族群
它前一波已經長得非常多
現在已經拉回來休息了
電力是比較沒有動
這個老AI伺服器也沒什麼動
最近以來你可以看
其實都還滿委屈的
就是這個小兩位數
還有甚至於這個個位數的反彈幅度
所以是比較委屈一點
那麼像台達電也是一樣
21%而已
所以我覺得這些股票
都是可以值得注意的
那因為這個老AI伺服器
大家可能都比較熟悉了
那我們今天講電力的
好 因為光寶科是創新高
今天一開牌沒多久就縮上去
沒錯 真的是
我們上禮拜來介紹
介紹了以後
他怎麼下來了
還有一點緊張這樣子
結果他今天就拉漲停了
好 那麼光寶科這支股票
真的很有意思
就是說他之前
其實都沒有什麼人注意他
應該說都會覺得這種股性
一定是買台大電
但是而台大電又下下去了
他反而變成又上了
對 沒錯
那他這個表現
其實他在營收方面
其實表現並沒有這麼亮眼
可是你就可以注意看
他7月份營收年增率37.6%那其實已經達到一個標準了已經達到一個標準了尤其是它上半年的EPS4.8元年增率百分之66這個就完全合乎標準了
而且它是取得兩家CSP客戶的認證
它接下來兩年
它大概可以貢獻10億美元
給它做營收的目標
所以這支股票它今天能夠漲停板
其實也合理
而且它今天的成交量
并没有放得很大
因为锁住了这个
对 所以它并没有放很大
盘装虽然有一度打开
可是没有放很大的话
表示怎么样
它筹码还是稳定的
所以这支股票应该还有更高点
可以值得期待
可是现在要不要去追高
我倒是觉得可能要考虑一下
要不要救救台达电
对 反过来了
对 没错
以前都先讲台达电
救救光宝科
对 没错
现在就是由光宝科
小弟变大哥了
那大哥就变掌门了
好 那麼其實呢
大家可以注意看一下
它的大量是出現在低點
有人接 這邊真的有人接
對 在低點的
然後它要回來
哇 又打回來了
打這個月線這邊撐住
那我是看啦
因為它今天的成交量
真的已經縮到一個自息量了
它今天只成要4000張
對啊 就不到4200張
你看這麼小的股
對 這麼小的量
已經收到自息量
理論上來講的話
它明天就應該有機會止跌了
可是當然反過來講
我們講到好的都要有點這個
預備的
萬一它明天是跳風開低盤的話
那可能就要小心一點
因為它月線跌破就要小心一點
可是基本面上來講
它是沒有什麼大問題的
上半年EPS17.59元
年代將近89%
那外資預估呢
它2020年的EPS是65.5元
所以我們用它今天的收盤價
來算它的預估本益比的話
才26倍
26倍來講的話
對台大電來講
其實是一個偏低的本意比
所以我是覺得大家是可以在
持續觀察注意
最後一檔
這一次一定大家都沒有想到
我一定要稱你為勇士
勇者
其實是因為沒膽才會
才會接到這一檔
1519的華城
因為它離它的低點實在很近
它都在年限下了
對 它是很近
所以從這個技術面看
他有一點機會做一個
頭肩底的味道那當然成交量不足是他的他成交量現在只剩下1000張了大家都不做华城对 大家都不做它了好 那么都不做而且那为什么不做呢其实大家可以看
它7月份的营收是月增
可是是年减的
上半年营收也年减
可是它的这个EPS
还是年增率24.6%
表示怎么样
营收降低了
可是这个毛利率并没有降低
利润结构反而好
对 利润结构反而好了
那我们现在要讲
他為什麼他的營收未年減
因為很簡單
沒有零組件
而且公司的產能就是這麼大
他們也不想擴產
因為誰知道這一批做完了以後
下一批還會有這麼
這個榮景還會繼續下去
所以他們也不準備增產
所以現在他們就比較吃虧一點
可是大家注意看
AI資料中間還有台電的
強任電網計畫
還有美國電力基礎的建設
還有高科技建廠
那是今年營運域成長的主要動作
它有四个成长动能
就是它肯定在手订单是满的
现在看来以营收来说
就是出货的情况
有点递言了
有点递言
它除了他们的零组件
这个有缺口之外
那像他们在今年的时候
在美国那边
它出货出到美国去
它有20家客户在美国
它出货之后
它的问题在哪里
他们都是用铁路运输的
铁路的板车不够
好
缺东缺西啊
缺这些有的没有的
所以你看它因为BIAG的
这个零组件短缺
所以它的交货期呢
这一年到两年半到三年
这个很夸张对不对
所以这是我讲的
你说它不好吗
它真的是很好
可是呢你说它很好吗
它又有这些问题在
所以我今天会选
那怎么观察呢
会选这张股票的主要原因是
如果万一这个大盘还要下来
大盤還要下來做個稀波回檔的話
那這種股票呢
因為它已經位階已經夠低了
而且本意也很低了
所以它會比較抗跌一些
那如果說呢
理論來講636塊
會是它的一個非常的強勁的支撐
所以在這裡可以注意看一下
它636塊能不能守得住
如果能守得住的話
那我們是覺得說
這張股票還是一張安全的股票
好 而且因為現在是利空比較多
因為數字不好
数字一旦好转
那就很值得期待了
今天非常谢谢永连老师谢谢
因素环绕
但是已经在这么低的位阶
就算大牌还要盘整或修正
它们也不容易再跌
反而有机会怎么样
涨的时候
营运转好的时候
出现往上攻的状态
这边提供给您了
那广告回来的话
题材练人号你就要上场咯
想当海海王吗
总是又快又急
今天出现黑K了
有没有机会压回找买点呢
另外发现
前跑哪去了
记忆体里面的模组
因为有高值利率的题材
像这样子的股票
还有谁
今天还有就来告诉您了
因为看到美债值利率往上跑
这对所谓高本梦比的科技股是压力
台股其实已经连续好几天
呈现资金往所谓有体质有席
有价值的股票去了
例如说像机体
今天涨到模组
模组就是高值利率的代表
那航运股其实也有值利率
但是涨得好凶
那今天的黑K
是介入的時間還是漲完了呢
我覺得其實應該都還有介入的機會
原因在於說因為美債殖利率
不是短向就回檔的
所以我們來看一下這一波
讓整個台股量縮圈
股市呈現觀望就是因為
你看到這是美國30年級公債殖利率
現在已經來到5.2到5.3左右了
那你會發現到這個我覺得蠻特別的是在於
今年3月份到4月份為什麼有漲這一段
就是因為中東地緣風險油價衝高
那其實簡單去講
當利率協率很高的往上漲的時候
通常股市表現都不好
那什麼時候台股會出現補量轉強
就看到美債率往下跌
那我覺得台股的一個資金行情
就有機會回流
但因為現在還沒有發生
所以你可以看到最近的情況是
連美國股市高估值的科技股
都漲不太動了
那最近電子全市股
開始以個股表現為主
今天什麼聯電啊
然後部分的一些所謂的
個別的像矽晶元股票轉強上來
那中小型股看到輪動非常快
最近股票就漲一天跌一天
對
昨天漲停 今天跌停的也很多
所以我覺得整個盤面上呈現了
在美股也是一樣
價值性
新的股票开始比较强
像美股的一些软体股啊
金融股啊 能源股啊
那反而是最近的半导体股都弱
上一拜美股的光通讯息
跌得还蛮重的
那这样情况
到底该怎么样操作呢
我觉得就回归到
从基本面的角度来看
这一拜徽达财报
财报之前传出来一个消息
徽达要调涨价格
是
那我觉得这个涨价啦
最少对法人来讲
明年的徽达的营收跟货币
都会在我上上调高
因为它整体的营收
再加了15%上去之後
想要控率會變得更大
那為什麼要調漲
就是因為
機體的缺貨還是關鍵的成本
機體漲太多了
所以整個伺服器價格
要跟著同步上漲
那整體上來看
整個HBM到D-REN到Netflash
價格都維持一個上漲的格局
所以我覺得整體上來看的話
整個機體族群
今天資金跑到哪裡
就像剛剛提到的
因為所謂的這個
美債率居高不下
所以資金就選擇什麼
去選擇一些高值率的股票
所以我們幫大家整理出來
其實你看到記憶體
今年上半年EPS
都是創造歷史新高
那銀州七月份很多
也創造歷史新高
都紅通了一片
那本益比你會發現到
比較低的在哪
從群聯以下這些模組廠
本益比都在10倍以下
好 當然這個大家會
爭相討論的是
到底能不能用
本益比來看記憶體
但無論如何今年賺這麼多錢
低本益比是一個事實
而且今年賺這麼多錢
明年的鼓勵也是很值得期待
你看群聯這個
今年的配息配了23.5元
但是他今年賺的錢
對不對
上半年就賺了187元了
對
那也代表說他明年
如果是400塊的話
他配息比較多
大概配個五成
就配200塊
200塊這個2135塊
算起來就是十倍本益比
好配200塊
突然覺得有點誘人
對 十倍的殖利率
所以這個好像就是看起來
就是10%殖利率看起來
就好像蠻吸引人的
所以你看到今天盤面上
像所謂的
金豪科
像創建威剛等等股價
在今天盤中
其實在記憶表現非常亮眼
我覺得都跟市場資金開始尋找
這種值率超過5%以上的公司有關
這一組本來就是偏高值利率的
明年就更應該會是高值利率了
對 而且現在已經來到8月份了
大概9月10月就開始陸續調整
明年高配息的股票
會納入到新增的高股底成分股
所以我也相信有一些資金
可能提前在算這種東西
提前在做一個卡位所以大家可以關注一下就是说这些股票的续航力到多少目前来看的话比较偏向就是說它是資金的避風港並不是成為記憶當中的主流因為創高的還是在納爾科
對 像信豪科也變成
快到創高率是新高
我覺得這些都是
看起來線也比較強
但摸出場我覺得比較偏向
落後不上行的
那我們來看一下
這些相關個股的表現
群聯真的是超級多人關心它
潘董也到處
就是去宣揚自己加的好
但是股價就是
不是沒談
但是就是開始進入到
也是盤整的狀態
對 如果我們先講
舊籌碼還是很醜
因為外資雖然說有買
就是怎麼講都不買單
買盤不多
但最主要是投信
不知道為什麼
就對群聯特別的感冒
一直在賣
那這波段你看
其實投信我記得賣超群聯
賣到現在可能
總庫存大概不到4000張
從原本大概高峰期
1萬多張賣到快要4000張
所以代表說這一波
我覺得投信對群聯
是比較有疑慮的
那這疑慮來自於哪
我覺得如果以群人基本面來看
沒有看到太大的敗向
整體公司也跟你講說
轉型到AI
消費電子的佔比不到10%
但是我覺得反而還是不買單
但我們回歸到現行來看
它這一波你可以看到
它上去之後碰到季線就壓回來
今天也是耶
對 代表它中期均線的
所謂的空方態勢沒有扭轉
那這個扭轉的機會來自於哪
你可以看到季線
目前扣椅在這個地方
對上去
所以它大概未來
將近一個禮拜的時間
會來到這個相對低點
這低點對過來
就大概在2250块附近
那也代表说
如果在未来一个礼拜之内
群联能够占到这一根黑黑棒
这根黑棒是出大量的
那是公布财报那一天
财报出来这个120几块
然后就股价居然是出现了大跌
就有点利多实现
对 那我觉得也代表说
这个大量高点越过的话
搭配季线慢慢转平上弯
也许就有机会重新做个补涨
那当然目前来看
还是法人要重新再来买方
好重要
所以我覺得目前來看
群體因為是老大
他有點在觀望
但是你會發現到
像創建
他線型就做好了
他相對支架強蠻多的
雖然今天也是一個
算十字線
對
那你看他季線
同樣也是要往下扣
季線目前是一個下彎格局
但即將要轉為上彎了
那所有軍艦存電
多頭的排列
所以反而我覺得
創建在現階段來看的話
線型相對比較強一些
那也代表創建
你如果去把這個
模式長少一遍的話
然後發現到創建 圍鋼 雨簪 石泉其實都佔到基建以上了所以看起來記憶體模組廠這個區塊看起來由這些中小型的股票慢慢有轉強的態勢所以大家可以去觀察一下如果記憶體的多方輪動
開始這個製造廠
IC設計 模組跟封測
慢慢有越來越多股票
站穩基建的話
也許這個族群
它在補量之後就有機會轉強
好 也看一下投信態度
因為之前創建也算是高股息
喜歡的一支股票啦
對 那時候被剔除啦
那我覺得接下來可能
因為廠多被剔除嘛
有可能接下来从这边纳会
因为回到相对比较低档位置
那接下来当然很关心
大家关心这个金豪科
他好活泼
下去马上涨停回来
对 因为前波这个是历史新高
然后股价回不到月线
就再往上跳高上去了
那我觉得也是在于说
因为金豪科毕竟今年上半年
赚了二几块钱
对啦
那你说他会不会高配息
我觉得可能配息率
没有那么高啦
但只能你上来看
因为他是有IC设计搭配
所谓记忆体模组的一个
这个题材
看起来我觉得
短段来看它陷阱比较强的
那金豪科预创跟艾普
其实我觉得陷阱目前看起来
没有那么整齐
所以大家可能要留意到
金豪科如果冲的比较快的话
也许比较最高
对啊 可能要等到整个族群转强
或等到IC设计的连巴科转强之后
我觉得这个指标性比较大
那奈亚科但之前讲的时候
它也涨了一段段上来
有创业性高
那今天我觉得比较可惜
因为今天被三星拖累下来
它尾盘杀下去了
对 所以三星今天跌的7%多
納克尾盤 沙尾盤就跌到
所謂的無日限時期限被跌破了
但我覺得其實納克重點在於
他時期限的關卡
能不能重新站回去
上市跌破很快站回去
如果說明後天
能夠站穩時期限的話
我覺得他還是有機會去挑戰
歷史新高
因為他的籌碼
算是在記憶當中比較漂亮的
他大概就是
全記憶體裡面的第一名
就是外資投信
法人大戶都喜歡他
對 就是記憶體的全村的希望
也是全球的希望
因為全球也只有他在創新高
全球的希望
已經到這種程度
對 因為全球很多發
記憶體的ETF
目前報酬率是
最好是納雅科
那我覺得他當然也代表
他的指標心意比較大
如果說能夠在近期
真一玩很快重新回到
創高軌道的話
其實整個記憶族群的
氣勢會更強
但現在問題就在說
大盤只有6000多億的量能
所以對納雅科
滑芳店這種大股本的公司來講
不是那麼友善
所以最近是呈現量能萎縮
我覺得走勢上來看
就會呈現
紅黑交錯的一個輪動
如果你有興趣的話
應該是稱它
黑黑棒拉回逢低成績
我覺得是比較好的做法那我們接下來看到大家很關心的航運族群好 航海王說來就來而且我發現還是蠻多觀眾或投資人十分關注這個肌肉記憶
當過航海王的記憶
對 因為航運股
就是像過去的記憶體一樣
吸引到非常多的人氣所在
那目前來看
我覺得航運股
現在是短向是強勢的
因為報價在漲
我們看到
SFI上個禮拜有公布出來
是連續四周上漲
但漲幅並沒有特別的多
那主要原因在於說
因為歐洲線的部分
它並沒有運價的上漲
但在美東跟美西漲幅還不錯
像美東快要創下歷史的
新高的價位
所以我們現在大概可以確定的是
整個航運股最少在
八九月份的營收跟獲利表現都還不錯
有基本面的支撐
那你會發現到
不只有台灣的航運股在漲
其實全球航運股都跟馬斯基一樣
如果大家去把所有股票少過一遍
紛紛創下今年
或是過去兩年的新高
所以我覺得這一波台灣的航運股
不是自己在漲
而是全球擴散的效益
馬斯基今年漲了47.17%
到上個禮拜
我繼續創下今年的新高
也是最近才漲上來的
就反映到最近運價的一個上漲
那我們會看到就是說
這個今天的航運族群
其實表現有一點點開高走低
是
那我覺得也跟盤的量太小有關
對啦 今天其實超級多都是上影線的
或是黑K
因為開高走低的關係
但最少你看到他們營收
或說本益比
都維持一個合理的階段
那大部分航運股
其實都是高股息成分股
所以也就符合我們剛剛講的
他們現在是具備低本幣比高值率
搭配漲價的題材
那我覺得就可以特別的留意了
那現在來看的話
但是大家會說
你看航運股漲這麼多了
還沒有機會上傳
對啊 就是一下子這樣
我們實在莫可奈何
萬海創今年新高真的好猛喔
對 那我們會覺得說
這一段時間的上漲
當然第一個就是
之前它都沒有漲到
對啊 所以籌碼乾淨
那最近滾量上工
是不是主力回來了
那主力回來就會特別喜歡去看
運價後續的報價的走勢
就有點類似過去去年記憶體
大家都緊盯了集邦的那個中文的報價
那現在我覺得航運股
你也去看相關的報價網站
像所謂的歐線期貨
最近這一個禮拜是天天在漲
那另外看到SCFI
或說大家如果有興趣
可以看德魯里的運價指數
也會領先SCFI
可能在運價短期之內
有機會維持一個
去長的一個格局
那當然指標局就看到
萬海是滾量上工
反正在買方
所以最近連投信
都在大買萬海
所以我覺得它的陷阱的部分
你就是不要追高啦
沿著五日線去做多
那我們講過去航海的關心是
跌破十字線你就走
那就代表說它短線
我覺得有這樣一個操作關心存在
那我覺得這種強勢的股票
你就不用去預設它高點
目前全球的航商還在漲
運價還在漲
法人籌碼還在的話
我覺得都可以偏多來操作
那你說萬海真的是
短線上這種高楊角
長那麼多的話
你可以去考慮比較穩健的長榮
好 比較大隻的
但也長不少喔
也蠻陡的喔
這一波
對 但因為你看
萬海的無綠線關係那麼大
長榮是幾乎貼著無綠線
慢慢墊高的
所以它是一個比較穩健的標的
目前是外資投信
大戶都站在買方
那我覺得長榮
當然它業績的穩定度
比萬海來得更好
所以如果說
大家是那種以長線的角度
就是你想要純股的
或是說
你想要做一個波段操作的話
我覺得長榮應該是說
如果有靠近到無綠線
可以縫低承接
那它離實線比較遠
所以代表你買它的話
你可能就是要分批進場
去做一些所謂的分批的佈局
它是航運股的龍頭
那現在也是在全球的貨櫃航運
如果是買ETF的話
全中也是蠻高的一家公司
我覺得具備代表性
好 那我們接下來看到所謂的
散裝航運
好 當然這個因為981也買
大家也格外留意
但今天也是吃了一個大黑客
而且他們今天都放量
對 我覺得就是有一點點
因為今天整個大盤是開高走低
所以這種漲多個股
我覺得就有一些
短線下策的一個賣壓
那散裝航運我覺得重點
還是看BTI BCI指數
其實最近他們的漲是沒有像貨櫃
行業的報價來那麼強
所以看到這一波
我覺得是跟著漲上來的
但惠昂畢竟他今年上半年
或是今年前七個月
都交錯好的成績單
那也是高股息的一個代表股
所以他也是一樣
既然他是沿著無線往上走高的話
我覺得如果是你空手人
也許靠近五到五線
你可以做一個逢跌的成績
一樣跌破十字線
你再說出場
我覺得做一個順勢操作
應該沒有太大問題
因為反而充滿還在
那星星當然就是郵輪的代表
好 大家要知道有一個載版的星星
還有一個散裝的星星
但是這個價格差滿多的
對一個一千塊一個三十幾塊
那我覺得星星它的特性在於說
因為它跟所謂的
這個中東的郵輪的報價有關
那先來看的話
整個郵輪還是面臨到
很嚴峻的塞櫃的情況
塞港的情況
所以我覺得郵價的後續上漲
對星星來講是有幫助的
它本益比在散裝當中算是比較偏低的所以只是說股性不好啦所以你今天紅黑交錯的話你就買黑不買紅整體上來看也是有機會軍營排列之後法人買方如果能夠回流的話
應該是有後續的表現空間
好 所以大家盯一下法人
盯一下航運的報價
舊的記憶又回來了
把熟悉的網站再度打開
希望大家這一波
能夠順利當上航海王
好 非常謝謝哈美哥
哈美哥有提到
不管美股台股
现在风都吹向了这些
有殖利率或是获利保护的公司
那在台湾来说的话
其实投信的筹码
或者说法人筹码真的很重要
因为项目组场
缴出再好的成绩单
都要法人认同
以及接下来有很多的高股息
可能要评估换股的时候
有没有重新的把它们换进去
这样子他们的市场的共识
才会更加的集中
但殖利率是毋庸置疑
是很保底的一件事
要当航海王
赶快网站拿出来
到底是集装箱指数
欧陷期货等等的
之前会查的一定要拿出来查
因为现在法人对于航运股的共识反而是高的
就是要报价持续上扬
这边提供给您了
好广告回来的话
云翔哥要来讲了
不要忘记涨价概念股
七阶元环球金出来说了
真的要涨价了啦
那涨价的风潮延续的话
会扩散到功率元件
10月也要涨
还有SpaceX升空了
我们的低轨卫星概念股
现在的状况如何呢
看高做低哦
好 两手盘整的时候
大家就会忽然觉得
好像没信心了
但不要忘记
之前我们常常提到的
涨价概念
如果他们现在反而是一个
比较低位阶的
不应该是
您要好好注意他的时间吗
好 这边来请教云翔哥了
云翔哥正在参加比赛
对 加油
放云翔哥加油
这个月底就见分校了
好 但是我們先來看漲價概念股
尤其是矽晶圓在這一波反彈
算是比較吃力的
但是他們也講了
不管長約或是現貨價都要漲價了
功率半導體也是
再來的話所謂的SpaceX
終於已經往上飛了
可是我們的低股位性概念股
還滿低的
好 那先看一下
因為我覺得大盤還是要
稍微關注一下
那目前來講
對 我是覺得比較黏
不過本來這樣子也符合
我自己的這個看法
就是說我認為橫向走
是一個比較具優勢的因為你要直接越過這個48000多除非这个量就供到1.5兆那今天剩下5000多亿不过这个应该刚
那个时空有讲
对 这南部的问题
对 希望这个
南部没什么灾情
大家明天赶快归队
你还是需要量
赶快放出来
对 要放出来
那基本上还是会比较安全
因为目前看起来是
优势是这个
月线来讲它是已经往上
月线变往上了
那今天来讲因为刚好一个黑K
所以现在这个季线目前还是没有站稳
那不过我觉得说这个量有稍微起来
基本上横移慢慢的还是可以站过去了
那尽量来讲就是
在这样比较没有量的情况下
我自己会稍微避开一些比较高价或者是全值
因为这个量不足的情况下
你这些高价股不容易推升
当然它的业绩它的基本面要够好
確實如果今天漲幅
平常跑拉出來
還滿都是低
對 中低價
然後大概有業績
那如果可以找到說
它已經整理過後呢
在右邊產生一些底部型態
所以我等一下會大概講一些
就是像橫盤突破最近有
那這個倒頭肩的這個型態
或WD
我覺得這些基本上
如果已經有完成了
那當然又多了一個
所謂的一個支撐的一個力道
是 倒頭肩就是頭肩底的意思嗎
對 頭肩底
西晶園今天還滿強的
因为这个
环球金的董事长
对
那已经有谈到说
可能要涨价
所以涨价大概一成
大概10%起跳了
所以当然12寸
它是主要的一个阻力
所以12寸8寸6寸
基本上大概都有涨价的一个空间
那其实来讲就是说
等了很久了
终于等到了
对
因为其实很多
当然它下面的一些
下游都在涨
是
对
那其实这个我们讲说
这个MOSFI这一块
就是我们讲说功率元件
接近涨两波了
那第三波在10月份来讲
也已经讲说第三波
应该10月份会涨大概接近15%左右
所以也大概是也等同是
等于上下游这一块
基本上全部都在动
因为我觉得合理
因为整个AI伺服器这一块
需求量这么大情况下
那当然这些都会用到
所以我倒觉得说
如果以这样的一个看法来讲
我倒觉得说细晶圆这一块
一直延伸到这个所谓的功率元件
我倒覺得說可能都要稍微注意一下
對 那這一塊來講 對大概我們大家有提了信心機源跟公路員我大概稍微整理出來那主要吸金源來講當然是看這兩次 對
看環球晶
然後再來就看媽媽中美晶
那環球晶基本上我覺得說
它第二季出來還不錯
大概有到7塊9
那其實它第二月份有一個
認列 試創的 對
可是第二季也認列的
這個股價的一個上升
也就同樣一支股票
它一個任列損失一個
所以基本上等於是
這個完全是本業了
對 所以以本業來講
我覺得還不錯
也等於有到
它原本想要的一個估值
因為2026年的估值
大概估大概21塊多
所以看起來是有朝這個方向走
不過本業還是比較高
那我倒覺得以這樣來講
我當然會去看他的媽媽
為什麼
因為對他來講
他的股本大概六十幾億
那他的股本是接近50億
那他本來就是他獲利
它百分之50
所以它收益的部分
它都要稍微要等一半
要上交给它
所以你看就是说
基本上如果它就算9块钱
它本益比才20倍
为什么
因为它才180几块
我觉得基本上
它应该会慢慢往上拉近
因为这个距离有点远
那公益元件来讲
就是大家可能比较关注
像强茂 德威
MOSFIN基本上
当然这一块来讲
这是主要的一个
大家会看的一个部分
那他们的本益比
大概落到大概28
对
EP大概在4块多到9块多
可是价格来讲
基本上也多到100多块到200多块
所以以这块来讲
就是说确实啦
它的业绩是有成长
从企业的营收来讲
看起来是YOY跟MOM
基本上都是增长
那这个获利Q1跟Q3都是增长
所以都是一个成长
那我倒觉得说可能这一支
我可以跟大家来讲一下看一下
为什么
因为博胜这一支来讲
它是属于供利元件这一块
不过它比较偏向
它是一个IC设计
晶片的一个设计
那你可以发现说
它100多块的一个股价来讲
它的月营收都创高
对 那另外来讲
就是它的一个
营收的YY来讲是63%左右
那EPS来讲就是
今年已经到
上半年到大概3.5块左右
所以如果今年雇到10块钱
它的本预非常低
大概只有15倍
這個我們大家可以來看一下
我們先看一下這個
吸金源的部分
那中美金跟環球金
我覺得可以這樣看就是說
因為環球金本來是走一個
很漂亮的一個
〔此段辨識失敗，約 40:00 起〕